[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir stehen vor dem scb fehlt sonder
thorium neben mir steht lars klingbeil
der reise kritik bei der spd neu
aufgelegt ich freue mich dass mit der
natur um ist ein gruseliges irrenhaus
glauben sie es wird parallel geben zur
spd parteizentrale
ist jetzt der scheiß frage direkt am
anfang nicht so liebt mich nicht mal
gucken ich beantworte die frage nachher
aber auch in den letzten tagen war das
schon ein bisschen was dran ja
grauenhaft aber so bauen dass nicht das
können wir nicht
natürlich drin bleiben weil ich finde
ich ja leider absolut dann würden wir
jetzt in den eckpunkten und raten sie
mal wer vor geld
[Musik]
wir sind in einer inzwischen
geschlossenen psychiatrie in der
jahrelang dubiose experimente
durchgeführt wurden also im prinzip das
was sie haben einen fehler gemacht haben
dafür müssen wir einige rätsel lösen und
wir müssen eng zusammen arbeiten wir
weiter die beiden kennen und die
verrückt gewordene chef ernst sind
mittlerweile tot die spuckt auch noch
das auch als kleine
und ich darf ja alles auseinander nehmen
anfassen suchen sie dürfen alles
anfassen inklusive mich wenn ich zu
[Musik]
lange jetzt kommen die spieler drauf zu
gewähren
[Musik]
das medikament ist wirklich sein dass
bei einem medikament das müssen wir
jetzt sieht und die fast alle
medikamente erst mal wieder eintauchen
ein bisschen hin dass textilien wäre
meine hinweis für den schlüssigsten
durch zusätzlich sie die gegen alles
vision alles anpassen und die anschlüsse
von sehr guten sowie sind aber recht
entspannt wenn ich sage dass sie
eventuell stärken ich weiß ja was mich
draußen erwartet
kann man die zahlen sind in rot als
schöne farbe das kommt
jetzt schauen wir sind jetzt erwartet
die spannung steigt wie hoch ist die
fahrt bis 22 zumindestens starke nerven
haben ich verstehe ja gucken was sein
sagt
[Musik]
welchen parteikollegen würden sie hier
gern mal für ein paar minuten einsparen
welchen auch für ein bisschen länger von
den eigenen leuten kein anderer das
jetzt eine gute frage den linden extrem
wir selbst schuld wenn er nicht weg
gerannt wäre
hier könnte man ihn auch festhalten das
stimmt hier kommt der gar nicht raus und
dann hätte der regiert und dann wäre
mein leben echt entspannt geworden
martin schulz sein ja damals gefragt ob
ich generalsekretär werde in der
opposition partei erneuern jamaika kommt
und dann habe ich ja gesagt und dann hat
sich die grundlage verändert und das hat
mein leben schon sehr stressig gemacht
also mit mir passt ganz gut rollen
wir haben eine perfekt wir versuchen
irgendwie ich sagte okay
genau diese punkte hole sich
diese engels gedacht
das ist super
sie lauten direkt gegen eine wand oder
wie man meine spd sagt ein ganz normaler
tag oder auch noch bewegen kann man ja
anfangen
jetzt muss ich jetzt suchen genau also
ich dass eine tür eine tür und das aber
kein schloss dran vielleicht machen wir
aber diese botschaft ist wieder hilft
ihnen das genau
heavy metal das theater ist er noch
nicht so kennen sie pantheon die band
das würde jetzt und dass wir auch so
typischen eher weichere musik über
pantera habe ich früher für motiv selbst
viel musik gemacht dass sie in jahre
lang zwölf jahre lang auf der bühne
gestanden und rockmusik gemacht dh wenn
sie jetzt sagen würden
wir brauchen ein anderes wird auch in
andere finde ich ein anderen mindset in
der partei also dass auch die konflikte
weil vor 20 jahren mal der mit dem und
das zieht sich bis heute durch
und das nervt mich als jüngeren
tierischer es darum das muss aufhören
wir müssen jetzt gucken dass wir dass
wir mal ein teamspiel wirklich
hinkriegen nicht nur in interviews das
sagen sondern es muss wirklich
funktionieren ich habe einen anderen
anspruch an politik und jeder muss jetzt
begreifen dass die spd tief in den
abgrund gucken kann gerade wenn man
diese umfragen sieht und deswegen muss
es sicher
[Musik]
nicht richtig cool
der tresor der frisur so dass eine
visitenkarte drin von enoch warte man
den namen schon morgen vorgelesen heute
alte man sieht eine telefonnummer darauf
dass heißt es geht im weitesten sinn um
nur das habe ich schon gesehen
ich lese ihnen die wieder mal vor die
telefonnummer wäre 97 82 14 08
und der geht vor das ist das prinzip des
spiels aber das ist doch jetzt wirklich
gruselig oder aber nicht so wir haben
sie haben sie keine kein blut sehen sie
eigentlich nicht dann ist das wirklich
müsste sie
klar und sie kennen das aus der
bürgerstiftung nämlich jetzt 16 also ich
vertraue ihm ja ja das ist auch so
und wissen sie was das allerwichtigste
ist ja ich hätte gar nicht anstellen das
vom privat gemacht aber das ganz
entspannt ich bleibe einfach jetzt hier
sagen sie mir ein paar wochen bescheid
der neue spd-vorsitzende sich wieder ab
hier ist mir vielleicht auch als
verloren dass das vielleicht auch ein
problem
das nenne ich mal mit erfahrung heraus
zu kommen müssen wir ein lied singen
sie unterstützen ja aber da haben wir
eine partei die leute schlechte
erfahrungen gemacht auch mit der
heute-show jungs haben sie stellt er sie
können mich gerne mal wieder feststellen
aber singen tue ich nicht weiter sich zu
sehen
sie hat das gut gemacht jetzt auf einmal
drei minuten
ich weiß mit dingen im fernsehen zu
london police das können sie sehen so
locker ist doch ganz gut weil wir sind
dann auch so sie singen und ich komme
aus aber dort sind irgendwann geben
ich klatsche klatschen nach klassen
[Applaus]
das war jetzt wirklich nicht immer gut
an das 19
das ist der letzte okay es ist der
schalterraum und es geht um diese
schalter die version 1 und 14 jahre also
die spd kann sehr zufrieden sein mit dem
ergebnis der europawahl kann sie nicht
die spd kann generell sehr zufrieden
sein mit der heutigen wahl gesagt die
spd muss sich dringend von der groko
verabschieden
nein nicht dringend sie haben jetzt ja
gemacht ich wollte ob sie aufpassen aber
sie eine meldung gewesen dass der
generalsekretär heute show die groko
beendet ja aber jetzt haben sie zerstört
andrea nahles für eine bei allen
beliebte parteivorsitzenden also bei mir
ja aber ja befürchtet gesagt der
rückhalt fehlte also war sie nicht
überall beliebt also muss ich jetzt
runter
sie war nicht überall beliebt genau sie
müssen jetzt ja noch 1 0 ist ja nach bei
der letzten wahl spd gewählt sonst dass
er durch es auch frost
ich hatte heute sehr viel spaß und
kommen gerne wieder sehr gut und sehr
schwer haben es ganz okay gemacht
jetzt muss ich bevor es weitergeht nicht
sagen oder sie haben eine frage falsch
eine frage falsch mache dann ist das
jetzt einmal wissen sie dass ich nicht
spd gewählt habe über der letzte ist
eine andere frage als es ist ich komme
hier nur raus wenn wir die gruppen
wenn sie sich für deren verabschieden
das ist schon unter machen wirklich ja
wirklich machen sie es wie kommen sie
nicht auf einen neuen habe ich hier
unterstützung und die ganze heute schon
sehr gut einmal der schlüssel umdrehen
und das gerade ein licht an gegangen und
wir sehen die tote stelle ärzte die
herumspukt
es ist einer dieser name ist die
chefärzte dir noch spuckt und sie wissen
wir sind von der heute-show wir sind
nicht aus politischen unglaublich witzig
also man kann es andrea nicht sein wenn
sie witzig sind als 130 hoch wir jetzt
drei mal andrea der andrea und sieht
sich an der kordel und dann zusammen
ziehen ja und dann ist alles gut
andrea erreicht
drei sekunden aber ich will noch ein
bisschen spannung erzeugen die türsteher
zu machen 32 geschafft sie haben es
geschafft wir haben an allen strecken
dürfen weitermachen
ja also sie sie haben gewonnen aber es
ist wahrscheinlich so sein wie nach der
letzten bundestagswahl die so zum ofen
wir sind frei gelassen dass sie wieder
einstellen und mit offenen augen in dem
heft aber demokratie koalition beendet
haben wir schon na ja also ich muss
jetzt ins willy-brandt-haus nicht teil
dass da jetzt mit und simon zum
wahlkampf germanisten stunde im westen
und trifft die richtigen entscheidungen
danke ja ich bin hier immer noch im
willy brandt haus und kleiner scherz
lars klingbeil es noch nebenan und
probiert gerade verschiedene
zwangsjacken an falls ihr die spd doch
noch ganz übernehmen muss klingbeil
brauchen sie hilfe
ich gehe mal besser nach gruppen in der
zwischenzeit könnt ihr auch gefällt mir
drücken und diesen kanal abonnieren
[Musik]